he is the front runner for the job as
Britain's next prime minister but rushi
sunak is proceeding cautiously a short
written statement promising Integrity
professionalism and accountability and
then off to Rally's support
the only other declared candidate is
cabinet minister Penny Morden she has
backing but as yet not enough to hit the
magic mark of 100 mp supporting her to
get into a runoff election
I am very confident about the progress
we are making and I will say to you that
I am in this to win it I think it's
important for our party we have a
contest I am very confident about our
numbers and it's I the reason why I'm
doing this is because I think I am best
place to bring the party together
both had been waiting to see what Boris
Johnson was going to do he flew in from
holiday at the weekend to Rally support
for a political comeback
his resignation almost four months ago
led to Liz trust being elected as
conservative party leader and prime
minister uh Mr Speaker I can I can tell
that but in a statement late on Sunday
he admitted there would be no political
Resurrection for him saying I believe I
am well pleased to deliver a
conservative victory in 2024 and tonight
I can confirm that I have cleared the
very high hurdle of 102 nominations
including a proposer and a seconder and
I could put my nomination in tomorrow
you can't govern effectively unless you
have a United party in Parliament and
that was a huge concern for some
conservative MPS I've never known of
this sort of ranker and Division and it
is very destabilizing uh destabilizing
for the party destabilizing for the
country
so for now only one Contender sunac has
the support to meet the 100 mp threshold
If That Remains the case he will be the
new conservative leader and the new
prime minister in what will be a
coronation rather than a contest Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera London